Muhammad, how you doing?
>> Hey,
>> can you hear me?
>> Yeah, you're a Muslim.
>> Yeah, well, we've spoken few one, two
time, one times before.
>> Okay, nice. Nice.
>> Happy birthday, Avery. First of all, uh
appreciate it.
>> All right, I I'll just get to the point
directly. You were talking about uh 54,
the books of tribulations of the last
time.
>> So, I'm sorry, say that again because
the the might cut out. What' you say? uh
you wanted to talk about u the hadith
right okay so uh I'm reading this if
this young so anas reported that a
person asked Allah's messenger as to
when the last hour would come
>> he had in his presence a young boy of
the ansar who was called Muhammad
Allah's messenger said if this young boy
lives which means he doesn't know if
he's going to live or not
>> he may not grow very old till he would
see the last hour coming
So over here what we can understand that
the prophet Muhammad he didn't
necessarily know the when the last hour
is and he's trying to use the young kid
as an example like if this boy even gets
to live he may not live long enough to
see the last hour.
>> So that is basically
>> no no
>> that's basically the Okay.
>> No brother he says that if he does live
long enough he'll see the last hour. He
will see it. See it's written there if
this young boy lives
he may not grow very old till he would
see.
>> Yeah. The last hour.
>> So in the second part of the sentence he
may not grow very old till he may till
he would see.
>> So he won't be much older until the last
hour comes.
>> But no over here it's trying to say that
that kid might not even have that chance
of coming to that point.
>> Yeah. You're right. He may not come to
the point of living long enough to see
the last hour. But if he were to live
long enough, if he were to grow old, it
will happen in his lifetime. He'll see
it.
>> All right. Now, let me just like uh give
you more supporting evidence just so
that I can tell you why what I'm saying
is right and what you're saying is a
little bit confusing.
I have two Quranic verses that justifies
why Prophet Muhammad didn't give this as
a prophecy rather he didn't have the
knowledge of it at all. So in Quran 7
>> brother you don't have to do
>> one
>> you don't you don't have you don't have
to do that I agree with you that
Muhammad does not know the exact day of
the last hour I agree with you what
however
>> then he wouldn't say
>> he but he did though he gave a time
frame he didn't know when exactly but he
gave a time frame which was in the
lifespan of that boy
>> yeah brother but you have to understand
that when he said that sentence right it
first of all it's an English
translation. So I'm giving you my best
understanding. And second of all, uh
there is an understanding which is he's
trying to say in an empathetic way that
if this boy gets to live because someone
asked him when is the last hour and it's
just everybody's curiosity, right? So as
you know Allah's messenger, what does he
do? He says this kid that's in his
presence that if this young boy lives he
may not grow very old till he would see
the last hour coming to you. He was
trying to give an answer to Anus that if
this boy lives he he won't be able to
see it maybe you know but it's not like
a prophecy over here because if this was
a prophecy he would give an exact exact
time he would give an exact exact
sentence right
>> let's do this together
>> okay brother
>> can you see the screen is it too small
>> okay
>> no it's okay
>> if this young boy lives he may not grow
very old till he would see the last hour
coming to you.
>> Yeah.
>> So, this directly says, and thank you
Casey Coupe for the birthday wish.
Appreciate you. She says, "Yahbar."
That's right. If he grows old, he will
see the last hour coming. Correct?
>> Look, the second part of the sentence,
he may not grow very old.
>> Until what?
>> Until he would see till he would see the
last hour coming to you.
>> So, if he grows old, what will he see?
>> If he grows old,
>> so it's an if condition. Ex.
>> Exactly. What would he see? If he grows
old,
>> he he would see the last hour.
>> So the last hour would come in the in
the time in the lifespan of that boy if
he grew old, right?
>> Yes. But it's there's a may there's the
word may, you know, so because
>> so maybe he might die before that
happens, right? He may he may die in
that time span. However, that still
doesn't negate that that's a time span
that Muhammad gives for the last hour
that let's let's say let's say he like
in in the lifespan of this young boy
growing old. Let's say old is I don't
know 100 years old, right? Let's just
let's just give that. Let's say old is
100 years old from where he is. Let's
say he's probably what maybe 10 to 100
years old. If he grows very old, if he
grows old, let's say he grows to 100 or
whatever, he'll see the last hour coming
to you, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Let's say he dies in between that. Let's
say he dies at age 50. So, he didn't
grow very old,
>> but that still doesn't negate the time
span that that that lifespan is when the
last hour is going to come.
>> So, it doesn't
>> if he if he survived, he would have saw
it. If he died, he would not have seen
it.
>> Yeah. But it doesn't negate prophet
Muhammad's statement that this uh kid he
may not grow on there to re to see the
very last hour. You know look Avery at
the end of the day I just want to clear
this out uh for you that um you know
you'll find many many uh you know sahib
bukkaris and sahi muslims that that
these are all like you know like a side
note which you can use to be a better
Muslim right but as Muslims the most
important thing is the Quran and the
Quran is the final word right we can
look at too many of these other
>> you can't ignore you can't ignore how no
no you have to understand
>> central to your religion
>> it it is it is close to very central
I'll tell you why because it is at the
end of the day it is it is look the
Quran is god's word it's fully the oral
transmission
>> I know I know
>> it's the oral transmission of the god so
why do we
>> do you have revelation in is in hadith
>> sorry
>> do you have revelation in hadith
>> revelation in hadith yeah there are
prophecies over there and Exactly. If
any of those prophecies are false, is
Muhammad a true prophet?
>> That's what I'm trying to tell you. The
prophecy that I just read to you isn't a
false one and doesn't negate him.
>> If Muham if any of the prophecies that
Muhammad gives in authentic hadith, if
any of them are false,
>> is he a true prophet or a false prophet?
>> If if one of them is a false, he will
become a false prophet. But we have to
we cannot be naive on our parts as well.
You know what I mean? Just because
>> Yes. Let's not be naive.
Yeah, no problem. But you you just
mentioned if this young boy lives, he
may not grow very old till he No, what
I'm trying to say.
>> But when will the last hour according to
this statement when will the last hour
come?
>> See there nobody has that knowledge.
It's written in the Quran that nobody
has that knowledge except for God alone.
>> That's fine. But what does Muhammad say
here? When does Muhammad say the last
hour would come? In what time span? He
he says this in this way that the kid
might not get to see within his
lifetime. That's all. That doesn't have
to say that it's going to happen within
his lifetime.
>> He says the kid may be able to see it if
in his lifetime. If he grew old
>> he'll he he will he will see the last
it's if he grows old he will see the
last hour. It will come in his lifetime.
That's what he says. Correct.
>> See it it says he may not not he may
>> he may not what? He may not grow very
old till he would see the last hour. So
what you're trying to tell me
>> is coming in his lifetime. Meaning he he
won't he won't get much old. He won't
grow very old till he sees the last
hour. Like the last hour is going to
come in his lifetime before he gets very
old. That's what he's saying.
>> Brother, listen Avery. I think you know
I I think you're smarter than this
Avery. And I think you know you could be
of massive Listen, Avery, listen. You
could be of massive good to humanity
because you have the knowledge of Look,
look, let me be honest with you. All
right, it says over here he may not grow
very see the last hour, right? Listen,
come on, man.
>> Did you just say that you know I'm
smarter than this?
>> You are smart. You're playing with me
with semantics, brother. I'm just like,
see, listen,
man.
>> Listen, brother, man.
>> Okay, let me tell you something. As a
Muslim, what we need to acknowledge. As
a Muslim, you need to acknowledge our
history.
>> Nope. You need to acknowledge what your
prophet claims. And if your prophet is
making false claims, then you need to
not be naive. Don't be don't be, you
know, gullible and accept the facts and
the words that's in your face. That's
what you need to do. I don't care. The
language is in front of you.
>> Excuse me, Muhammad. Let's not play
games. We're smarter than that. You told
me I'm smarter than that. So, I'm going
I'm going to try to live up to your
expectation. I'm definitely smarter than
this to accept an explanation that goes
against my common sense and my reading
comprehension. I'm smarter than that,
Muhammad. So, when I see the words when
I see the words here that if this young
boy lives, he may not grow very old till
the last hour come to you. Till he would
see the last hour coming to you. my
reading comprehension because I went to
school and because I passed in in
>> I passed I'm sorry.
>> I I passed when it came to linguistics.
I I passed when it came to grammar. I
passed and I got my high school diploma.
I got some college credits and I was a
very good student in college, by the
way. And I did very well. Very well.
>> I I I think you I think you may have
been better than me for sure, brother.
for me. I'm just trying.
>> So when I So when I see this, please
when I see this, it would be insulting
to my intelligence to suggest it's other
than what it says. So do we agree that
according to what it says that the last
hour would come if that boy that that
that boy would see the last hour coming
if he lived if he lived long enough? If
he grew old, then it the la he would see
the last hour coming in his lifetime.
According to Muhammad,
>> if things worked out, right, then this
kid, if he lived enough to see the last
tower, he would have seen it. But he
didn't, right? So, that just goes to
show that this wasn't a prophecy.
>> Thank you. I appreciate you, man. Thank
you for Thank you. Take care of
yourself, man. See, when you guys come
up, I'm telling you, I need you guys.
Look, I've had conversations with
Muslims who were here like like one
Muslim most of my stream because this
Muslim was honest. He was direct. He
didn't play games. He didn't he, you
know, there was none of that. There
wasn't none of that. You guys and this
like the large breed of you, the large
batch of you Muslims are so dishonest
and you expect me to accept your
dishonesty
to to play with your dishonesty. Now, it
depends on what mood I'm in. I might,
you know, have fun with it or not, but
for the most part, you're not going to
last on the stage. You know what I'm
saying? Like the last guest, Nory, I I I
I was having fun with his dishonesty,
but that's that's that's not often. Stop
playing on our intelligence. When I say
our, I mean the 3,000 people that's
watching on YouTube and the 500 folks
that's watching on on Tik Tok. Stop
playing on us, man. We're not dumb. We
see the text. We read the text. And most
importantly, we comprehend what what the
heck we're reading. We're not a dumb
breed. We didn't come out of Islam.